[Music]
this was round
five of the us championship i had one
out of four going to the rest day i just
lost the lenderman with white
and the worst feeling
on a rest day is that you lost the game
before i think you just didn't test
and that you're playing fabio with black
with one out of four the next day i was
really down
on myself
for the majority of the rest but then
toward the evening i kind of got my wits
about me and i said all right let's
prepare because the last time i played
him in 2017
i i played a french and i got blown off
the board in 25 moves i didn't prepare
diligently i mixed up my prep
and he blew me off the board and i at
the very least
didn't want that to happen i was
determined
to get a decent position with black out
of the opening for once that tournament
after losing to darius and ray
essentially out of the opening
so i decided to pause all of the
sicilian and alaka and shenanigans and
go with what i know best
which is e45 and
fabio has been playing the rye lopez
almost um
almost exclusively uh in in the last
couple of months so i didn't really
prepare for much else to be honest i
briefly looked at the italian but
i was fully expecting that rylo because
he plays it
i i fluctuated here
between several different
possible variations in the past i mostly
played the main line a6 bishop a4 knight
f6
later against dominguez i played the
schliemann which i also contemplated but
fabi seemed to know it down pat
and then my eyes kind of settled on a
line that i faced with the white pieces
against our tamiya of a name chess thank
you my baby
and and that is called the deferred or
the delayed steinitz variation not the
delayed shaleem and the delayed steinens
the traditional steinitz is to go d6 in
this position which is still considered
a very solid move but but it's also very
passive it blocks the bishop and black
is worse here
the inclusion of a6 bishop a4
allows the extra option of b5 and that
has many concrete benefits for black
one of which is that
uh
you know you get the famous noah's ark
trap if white plays d4 here uh
traditionally black has responded with
v5 bishop b3 and now knight takes d4 and
this is a trap that i'm sure almost
everybody
or a lot of people in in the audience
probably know queen d4
and already black is winning with c5 and
the bishop is going to be trapped
between d5
first you have to
protect both the rook and the maid
threats of bishop b6 check bishop d7
queen d5 now the queen defends the rook
and you can go c4
okay so this is nothing to write home
about
uh obviously fabi knows not to play d4
and he decides to castle which is one of
the main lines together with c3
and um
okay so bishop d7 following
the sort of modern line that our tamiya
has been playing and a lot of people
have been resorting to this line of the
black
the funny thing is if you turn on
stockfish here
at first it gives like 0.7 for white
which is a lot even for the ray lopez
but if you let it sit
and if you delve really deeply into
these positions you often find that
uh that that stockfish kind of flounders
here and doesn't propose
particularly appealing ideas for white
so for example one very common thing
that you will see
and even modern computers do this i'm
going to rewind in just a second so
you know don't i'm just trying to get to
the appropriate position here for
example
the chess.com engine is recommending is
the top move d5
but
as you guys can probably understand this
is
maybe objectively better for white but
from a king's indian perspective it's
kind of like a dream position i'm
already kind of poised to play f5
and um i had no problem with with this
type of situation
um
so in these closed center type positions
the computer can still uh sometimes
falter
okay
so now let's go back
to bishop d7
um
against our tamiya i think i played c4
here kind of trying to get a marutzi
type position
it didn't go particularly well
and i think fabi plays
you know objectively best line which is
c3
knight f6 and now
very important move rookie one because
if white plays d4
then it turns out the black actually can
take this pawn
and you get a forced line that results
in a slightly better end game for white
but i had analyzed that end game very
very deeply and i i was confident that i
would be able to hold a draw
so the line here goes rookie one you
drop the knight back and basically you
get liquidation so d5 d5 bishop c6
bishop c6 queen d8
now rook d8 walks into kind of a
potential x-ray so you play king d8
knight e5 bishop d5 um
at this point
there are let me see
yeah at this point there are in the
database about
ten games seven games including nepo
against artemyev and by the way both
bishop b and bishop d5 here i think are
good moves
and it's like a 0.3 type advantage
because white's got a bit of a clamp
here and the king is weak
but
ultimately black consolidates due to the
two bishops i was not worried about this
i didn't think fabio
would burn his bridges like this right
and risk drawing the game
because he'd been struggling this
tournament so far
and indeed to my
you know non-surprise he goes rookie one
and now g6 so this is the whole
idea behind black setup you stein it's
often played bishop e7 in these
positions but this is tremendously
passive i mean you can just see bishops
on e7 and d7 like this is not the way
modern players tend to play and there's
nothing super wrong with this it's just
too passive
the modern treatment is to play g6 and
kind of played king's indian style
fiance of the bishop
and black is a little bit behind on
development on the king's side but it
turns out after d4 bishop g7 that
tactically everything is justified here
once again bishop c6
and de might look very appetizing
but black simply takes the pawn on e4
and on the next move black is going to
castle and
even if white takes on d6 you still
castle
this occurred in carjacking against
artemyev
and black has excellent compensation for
the pawn or sorry uh so again sir tammy
we're telling you we won that game it's
equal but
rooks are coming to d8 i mean you can
see
you know you don't even need to
calculate it to understand the black as
full compensation here for the pawn
and there's nothing else that y can do
here
um some of you tactically minded people
might notice this idea
but the problem when you fork a bishop
is that the bishop is capable of saving
both itself and the other forked piece
you bring it back to c6 and this was all
part of my prep
um
fabi
you know also knew this he was still in
his theory and so he plays knight b to
d2 developing and please feel free to
ask questions thank you pat you've been
and clarify stuff
i'm going too fast i'm happy to repeat
whatever needs repeating
i'm not going to do this twice so please
please feel free
um so knight bd2
and here comes uh a moment that i was
really proud of iii this is not a
novelty
by any means
but uh
well it almost is a novelty actually
there are only
three games in the database
uh with the move that i played here
and by transposition
after my next move there's only four
games in the database and i'm the only
sort of gm game
um we end up transposing on the 11th
move to
a more popular line which has about 30
games but still very uncommon
most common movers you guys might
probably unders
probably guess
is just a castle
it's just a castle
uh and we get you know this kind of
structure generally the bishop drops
back to c2 to solidify the center and i
think white is slightly better here
but having left sorry having left the
computer on for a long time
i discovered that there's a very
interesting and seemingly
anti-positional idea you take on d4
now what are we doing aren't we just
yielding the center isn't this
the whole point not to do this right
well
you know that's what it may seem like
visually but it turns out that because
of the slight awkwardness i think of
white's coordination
black has all these sudden tactical
ideas that allow me
to put
super significant pressure on white's
center
thank you only correct
what ideas are those
well
first of all it's not so easy for white
to make a move
because the bishop on c1 is hemmed in by
the knight and i had a game like this
earlier today i think
the typical rai lopez move is knight f1
but does anybody remember how
black can pounce in this position
and if you are a experienced try lopez
player you will notice that what's very
alarming about white's position is that
he hasn't played h3 that's often
punishable
what do i mean by anti-positional it
violates sort of what seems to be basic
positional principles one of which is
that you don't give up control of the
center unless you have to
so that's all that i really mean
so how do we punish white for not
playing h3
so bishop g4 is fine
but it's better to to start with b5 just
get this bishop
out of our hair
then go bishop g4
and you've got super
nasty pressure going on this d4 pawn i
mean if white plays h3 take the knight
and queen cannot capture white has to
ruin his pawn structure and that's a big
problem
so
it's just not easy to to hold everything
together bishop e3 is the continuation
that has occurred most frequently and
now you don't take on e4 in these
positions this is a classic trap
but instead you reroute this knight from
a5 to c4
and then the c pawn goes white black's
got a great position here
i was kind of hoping that he would
go for it but fabi's
fabi for a reason he goes h3
um
well again
people saying that this is too complex i
mean if you can isolate specifically the
things i'm saying that aren't making
sense
um you can
you can ask them and i'm happy to
clarify but hopefully
there isn't anything crazy going on so
far
all right
so um
why displayed age three
but now we have to try to find a way to
exploit
the drawback of the positioning of the
bishop on a4
and
still remember that the bishop on c1 is
as yet undeveloped
so
one of the things you can notice about
this position is the d3 square is a bit
of a sore spot in black in white's
position and that's exactly where we aim
with our knight just go knight before
looks a little bit artificial
but in fact after bishop takes d7 queen
takes d7 it turns out that it's not so
easy to defend
against all of these annoying threats
knight is coming to d3
how can white defend that square well
again knight f1 is the typical
prescription
but because we've moved the knight away
from c6
now the c pawn gets free
black starts to contest the center this
is approximately equal according to the
computer but i really like black's
position here it's kind of like a benoni
on steroids almost okay that should make
sense i mean if white plays d5 black can
just play c4 and forcibly drive the
knight into d3 amanda
black is already better
uh so fabi does not play knight f1 he
plays queen b3 still part of my prep
this move
stops black's ideas in my tracks i can't
play knight t3
and going back to c6 would be a huge bus
skill so first things first we support
the knight fabby kicks it away and only
now do we go back to c6
now
you might be thinking at this point well
what is the purpose of going knight
before and then back to c6 well we've
accomplished two things in doing so
first of all
white can't take the pawn because rook
fb traps the queen so that's out of the
question
number one is that we've traded light
squared bishops who does this benefit
but i i believe that it benefits black
because white's light squared bishop
when it sits on c2 supports the e4 pawn
now the e4 pawn is a little bit tender
and
you know as i beat you over the head
with the bishop the dark squared bishop
is
pretty lame at the moment
the third thing that we've gained is
this structure with a pawns on a5 and a3
is in black's favor as well and as
you'll see in just a little while
i can play the move a4
and sort of freeze
white's queen side i'm sure you've seen
this idea before in other openings
if y plays a4 then the b4 square is weak
and my knight is poised to occupy it
so
fabi
goes um
knight f1 which is the first move that i
had not looked at in my preparation
i had only looked at the concrete d5
which actually has
occurred in five games knight f1 has
occurred in three games including mine
now there's a very important detail
knight comes back to b8
and the consequence of d5 is that our
bishop is now open and the c5 square has
become a big weakness this knight is
going around through a6 to c5
we sack the pawn
we go to a6 and then on the next move we
go knight c5 with massive compensation
for the bond i mean again
if you just look at this position
visually it's not so hard to determine
that black is great comp
uh yeah it's still prep i was really
determined to do a good job with my prep
this game
this has occurred three times
and there's one high level
correspondence game one grandmaster game
and black black is in great shape and
also the b file
if you play the banco gambit i mean this
is like a
fantasy
right um
so
this did not happen and fabi was
probably out of his prep at this point
maybe he'd studied this at some point in
the past but probably didn't remember it
he was already taking his time
and he decides finally to go with this
move knight f1
but now as i indicated uh because we
have this
situation
uh maybe like three hours nothing insane
but it was just very effective because i
kind of predicted the right loop as i go
a4
again taking is impossible
so he drops the queen back to d3 and at
this point we are on our own
um
the next move didn't take me a long time
because it's a very natural follow-up to
the previous move a4
what does this move do it freezes white
spawns it also creates a stronghold on
b3
what should go on to that square well
generally knights
go to outposts
so knight a5 is a very typical move
fabio responds with bishop g5
okay developing his finally developing
his bishop i get my knight into b3
and uh he goes for kd1 so
he allows this knight to sit on the
outpost but now white has gotten all of
his pieces essentially into the game
um but i was happy with the outcome of
the opening my pieces are also all in
the game the position is just very
complicated and probably about equal
maybe a little bit better for white but
not convinced of that okay so i was
annoyed by the bishop so i decided to
tickle it with h6 and just see where
where he wants to put it
to my surprise he takes the knight on f6
i didn't expect that i thought he would
move the bishop back but okay this is
not a game deciding moment it's possible
he decides to trade
why did he decide to trade my guess
is that aga on bishop e3
he might have been concerned about
something like d5
e594 this is a typical idea maybe he
didn't like the look of this
and decided to eliminate the knight
while he had a chance
now he decides to eliminate the other
knight while he has a chance knight 1 to
d2 getting rid of this outpost
and this next move that i played is not
technically the computer's top move the
computer
just kind of suggests knight takes d2
what i didn't like about this position
is that i saw that white has this plan
of starting to push his center pawns at
495. i felt like if he drives that wedge
into my position the bishop might get
lame
that knight on the other hand has access
to a lot of key squares potentially
so maybe back to c4 or then later to e3
i felt like the knight could be better
than the bishop here
i know that sounds surprising
because right now the bishop is
quite good but
if white drives this pawn wedge in you
know you have to look at the long term
here
okay well i don't have the edge this is
equal i mean though the computer just
i mean i don't really know the reason
the move that i played isn't really a
mistake
it's it's
slightly
non not preferred over the other move
um
knight back to a5
this move took me a while it took me
maybe 10 minutes or so you could check
the time stamps on chess bomb
um and
i think maybe at this point he started
to get a little bit surprised because i
was you know playing very combatively i
wasn't simplifying
um what was the logic behind this move
actually quite simple
uh first of all i am forcing this knight
to remain on f3 which means that he
cannot push
f4 and e5 in a position like this is far
less effective because i can simply take
it
there's no f pawn to recapture with you
can't capture the d-pawn because the
queen is
hanging
it turns out as i found out after the
game that in this position white does
have
a pretty powerful resource that maybe
was the way for white to get an edge
does anybody see it
has to do with the undefended nature of
the bishop on f6 i've shown this type of
idea before
this is not a difficult move once you
look at this position
yeah knight e4 knight comes out to e4
the queen is now defended
after bishop g7
knight takes c5 comes in
and the knights are very strong so black
potentially can simplify
but
the idea of knight f6 and rook d7 i
think gives white maybe a slight
advantage according to the engine black
should be able to make a draw though
so this might have been
a more practical path than what he did
which is
knight b1
he there's this cat and mouse game going
on right he he allows my knight to get
back to b3
but
he doesn't really care about that what's
more important to fabby is to get his d2
knight into the game with knight c3
um
maybe not gabo i mean i'm not sure that
position requires more analysis i didn't
like this scenario because i felt like
the knight wasn't doing enough to
warrant
allowing white to coordinate his pieces
so i thought it was quite important here
to create a net with my pawns in order
to limit the mobility of this b19 and
that's where i came up with my next idea
which is to play b5 number one
and after sorry and after knight c3
which he didn't play
to play um
knight c4
and
it turns out that i have yet another
outpost on the queen side that's the
perk of having a superior pawn structure
and then once his
queen moves back let's say to c2 or
however he wants to defend b2b and i go
c6
and the knight on c3 has been sort of
fully restricted
i'm controlling d5 i'm def everything is
defended all the pawns defend each other
we're
we're gucci here this is good
um this is a good position something
similar happened in the game by
transposition
okay so i think
well knight c3 knight c4
it's not easy to play knight two because
once he plays rookie two knight d2
actually blocks
the rook's coverage of the pawn so
not so simple for white to untangle here
believe it or not knight d5 is possible
but doesn't do much i just drop my fish
back and then play c6
so
fabio goes queen c2 which is i think a
nice move
he's kind of waiting for me to go knight
c4 and then says gotcha i go knight bd2
and i get your knight out of c4
notice how he doesn't commit to the
placement of the b1 knight he waits for
me to put my cards on the table and show
where i want to put the knight of course
i don't show where i want to put the
knight i don't play into his hands
um yeah so now e5 is also quite a nasty
idea because it hits the bishop so i
play a prophylactic move i drop my
bishop back to a safer square
taking the sting out of the movie five
which now doesn't come with tempo can be
easily dealt with
um
okay so he goes knight c3
and i go c6 as as planned
i'm not in a hurry to put this knight on
c4 it's not going anywhere
he if he tries to bring the other knight
to d2 he loses d4 pawn
i think you can kind of see how the lack
of bishops is hurting white's control
over his set it looks like white's got
all his pieces where he wants them but
somehow
white's stuck in a little bit of
molasses thank you nauseous maximus
so
at this point fabi took a long time and
he was taking like 10-15 minutes
on each move and he started to get
himself into a little bit of time
pressure this is hour and a half for 40
moves and then an additional 30 minutes
so at this point i would say he had
about
35 minutes left i had maybe 45 minutes
and fabby decides to sort of change the
the arc of the game he goes e5
all right
um
now as i mentioned earlier
you know this the pawn break is not as
dangerous with the bishop now hiding on
g7 but it still is dangerous i mean if
i'm not careful i'm going to be caught
with my pants down here
so
to this end
i think that the instinctual move for a
lot of people here would be to play d5
but now the bishop is totally hemmed in
and white has a very simple plan of
preparing e6 you can get this knight
from e2 to f4 and then e6 is essentially
going to be unstoppable
so
i a lot of people have this knee-jerk
reaction to move the pawn forward but in
this case it's bad
another knee-jerk reaction is to take on
e5 this was possible
i didn't want to give white an open d
file
um
so i decided to sort of leave
everything as it is in the center just
focus on improving my position
and
i take the sting out of the potential
idea of e6 so i played rook feat
why would the e6 pawn break be so good
sure so
let's analyze a hypothetical scenario
let's say what black puts the knight on
c4 white puts the knight on f4 what's so
great about e6
it's the fact that the g6 pawn becomes a
tremendous weakness right if black's
pawn was on h7 i would not be so worried
about it
as it is um
as it is as it stands uh
once the knight sinks its down to g6
there's going to be trouble i'm not
saying that black is losing
also this knight from f4 can
reroute through d3 to c5 potentially
so whatever let's say rook a b8
um
e6 fb6 knight g6
and black's position starts to fall
apart at the scene and look at this
incredibly weak square look at the king
it's not good all right and you can
argue that black is can defend but it's
it's not fun to play such positions
black has no plan
so
rook f8
that's where it stands but fabi plays
knight e4 very natural move and again
he's tempting me into just into
committing the placement of the d-pawn
but still i don't do that i go knight c4
which is a very important move defending
the pawn on d6 and finally getting that
knight where it wants to be
and here the game enters
i would say out of the positional stage
and into the tactical stage right so far
there's been a lot of maneuvering we've
been positioning our pieces on
you know what we believe to be the best
squares now things kind of explode
um
and it they explode because fabi
decides on e takes d6
what is black's plan well black's plan
is to eventually take on e5 i mean if
white
procrastinates for too long i am going
to take on e5 and then try to win that e
pawn
okay so let's make a random move
here after d e d e
queen f5 for instance there's already a
pin going on this pawn on e5 is now a
huge weakness
so
i want to make something clear which is
that earlier i didn't want to take that
pawn because it would give white control
of the default but now there's become
you know the circumstances have changed
there's something more important just
that i can now win the c5 pawn and that
warrants something that i wouldn't do
earlier if that makes sense
you're constantly assessing and
reassessing
key ideas to see if the circumstance
have changed and
if they're now possible
you got to keep doing this at this level
i think
otherwise you missed opportunity so ed
knight d6 looks like black's chilling i
mean if white captures this is great for
us now the bishop is good we've got a
nice little
outpost on d5
but
of course as many of you guys know we
saw the game fabi has a very concrete
idea which is 95.
this looks really really scary
because taking is out of the question
everything just collapses instantly we
have to move the queen where can we move
it
well it's not so clear
we presumably have to move it somewhere
so that we preserve contact with the
knight right so queen c7 might seem like
the only move
but here simply white wins a pawn right
takes
d6 queen takes d6 and knight takes c6
and i was calculating this at first and
getting discouraged because after takes
takes
you know you might briefly
be tempted by rook c8 but knight e7 ends
the game here
and bishop takes d4 might seem like an
equalizing move but it's not everything
is hanging in the air
and the move queen e4 decides the game
because it x-rays the rook threatens 97
and threatens the bishop
this is
losing
for black i calculated this tonight
of course i had seen this idea when i
played knight c4 so i knew what i was
gonna do here
and who can remind me of the key move
without which
you know without this move i i would
have lost the game
um
this is a key key defensive idea
and that is not queen takes h3
you're on the right diagonal
it's queen to
queen to f5 that's right creating a pin
against the knight
very important resource okay he can't
take
he can't really take on c6 either
because because there's a pin and the 94
is under pressure in fact there's a nice
line queen c6 94 queen e4
looks like white has gotten out of the
woods but this very unassuming move f6
actually wins the night
that is a nice nice little detail
but fabi kind of has to go full steam
ahead he has to get rid of the screen
and that's why he plays g4 but
obviously this is a significant
weakening of the king
and now i dropped my queen back to e6
and here
fabi took you know another 15 minutes
getting himself down under 10 minutes
which was it that ended up being kind of
disastrous for him and he spent all this
time calculating the key line
which is knight d6 queen d6 knight c6
how has the move g4 changed
uh the landscape of the position
yeah i saw g4 well if we go back through
the initial line that we were
calculating
recall that queen e4 used to be the
winning move i was so i was
so happy when i saw this
remember now i just played g4
does this allow any additional resources
it does queen g3 check is not only a
saving grace but also just wins the game
for black this is this is the key
because this move now comes with check
and everything
falls so
bishop d4
is fine for black now fabio should have
gone for this because i think he might
have stopped calculating here if he went
a little bit further he would have seen
but after takes takes white has a
tremendously nasty move here
when it seems like black is totally out
of the woods does anybody see it
what is
the idea that
maybe he missed or he underestimated
there's a queen c6 forking the rook in
the pawn well no problem black defends
with rook v8 but boom comes rookie a
check
forcing the trade and amazingly white
returns takes the pawn defense b2 now
i had calculated to this point and
concluded that this should be a draw
the reason i came to that conclusion is
that the king is really weak
a and b
remember all a while ago i played a4 and
now i reap the rewards of that move
because why i don't think has any way to
ever really create a past pawn you know
if white plays b3
uh that's only asking for trouble due to
queen d1 i i don't think the king can
evacuate itself to anything resembling a
safe position every time it goes up to
g2 check on e4
there's nowhere to run
and computer confirms that you know this
is like point eight white has maybe some
attempts but it should be a draw with
careful play
b4
again queen a1 queen takes a3 there's
always going to be some fork
it's possible that fabby calculated this
and concluded that there were not enough
winning chances and i think he simply
underestimated the danger so having
calculated this
he rejects it and he decides instead to
go back to c3
this is where i pounced him this is
where i recognized that he was starting
to lose control of the game knight c3 is
a big mistake
so first things first we defend the c
pawn
knight burying ideas of knight takes c6
he can't do that because if queen takes
e1 check and we take everything here
okay does that make sense
now he can go back with his knight and
you know he did that ultimately but that
doesn't do anything right we can just
move the queen
instead fabio's rookie two so he's
clearly
putting the rook on a defended square
and now he threatens knight takes e6 but
here i made perhaps the most important
move of the game
i i had seen this idea a while back i
had seen this idea when i played queen
e6
and again
i'm reaping the rewards of the placement
of the a pawn that pawn on a4 creates a
strong hold on d3 now i used to put a
knight there
but now the circumstances have changed
and i put my queen on b3 queen b3
and
this
essentially forces a queen trait i mean
the pressure that the queen exerts is
immense so fatty takes
now this pawn on b3 is a monster it's
very hard to attack
and if god forbid white loses the b2
pawn well and this pawn is going to be
two steps away from promotion not to
mention the fact that the bishop is a
beast this knight is poised to go onto
c4
and white's position really starts
coming apart here
in addition he's in big time pressure
he's got 10 minutes for 10 moves
so fabi tries to
glue things together he brings his king
up to g2
um
sort of not really a waiting move but
improving his position kind of asking me
what i'm going to do next
but
i did not let him breathe
we've got to break through white's
position so c5 to eliminate the key d4
pawn
d takes e5
now another very important move
now i was tempted by rook takes c5 which
i calculated
and concluded that it led to a draw
takes
let's say rook takes c5
but here
for instance white could play rook e to
d2 and i don't think there's anything
impressive for black you can move the
rook back
threatening bishops e3 not a problem
white moves the knight back and i don't
think we can really get to that b2 pawn
in any realistic way it's too well
protected
too well protected this is probably a
draw
and at this point i was already sensing
that this might be an opportunity to
play the game of my life so instead i
keep my eyes on the prize which is that
you know we need to use the pawns and
pieces at my disposal to re remake the
position in my favor
and that's where i found the move knight
to c4
and this was according to the engine the
decisive mistake by fabi it's quite
telling that he played the next move
almost instantly he assumed that it was
forced and i'll tell you something else
i assumed that it was forced you both
assumed that white has to take that
knight
because how could you leave a monster
like this on c4
but you flip on the engine and you see
that white had one chance to draw the
game
and amazingly it's the move knight d3
and it's insane i'm not totally
convinced that it's a draw i haven't
looked at it on a high def
but basically the engine gives this
crazy line
first of all if you take on e2 and then
you take on b2
and at the end of the line white's gonna
have
not rook b1
because after bishop takes a3
rook takes b3 there is a very powerful
move b4 and c5 pawn is going to be lost
but can anybody spot
a really powerful drawing idea that
white has here
there's two moves that are kind of
similar in nature
it's not rook d3 either because that's
exactly the same thing as rook b1
rook d5 doesn't defend the pawn though
it's not rook d2 again you guys have to
realize that if the bishop takes the
pawn and then we advance this pawn to b2
the game is over
c6 i'll simply take it yes knight c1 is
correct
or knight d4
knight moves backwards to hit the pawn
if we take it it's a draw i mean the
rook comes to b1 and there's mass
liquidation
and if we play rook takes c5 the knight
takes b3 rook c3 and knight d4 hitting
the pawn and saving the game
if bishop takes a3
this is not a good move then after
knight takes b3 already white is better
because you can't take on c5 due to rook
c1 incredible
lines here and it appears that knight d3
would have saved the game
bishop takes c3 is another try by the
way and evaluating this position
correctly is also really really hard i
mean this looks so scary there's rook d
a there's b2
i'll spare you you know the the
the details
i still have to analyze this but i think
it's a draw
but of course fabi i mean this didn't
occur to either of us
and and so he takes on c4 and this is
essentially the decisive well
this and the next move formula form the
decisive mistakes or takes two and again
again
he plays instantly knight takes c2
for going perhaps the last chance to
muddy the waters which was this inter
mezzo knight d6
bishop takes c3 because both rooks are
hanging knight takes c8 bishop takes p2
and black probably should win this game
but
um
the engine
gives white some you know pretty decent
chances to draw
okay i'm not sure people are actually
interested in in the game
i just i want to make sure that i'm
making sense that people are following
or we're drawing near the end here okay
good
all right
so yeah i just needed some positive
reinforcement so knight takes c2 okay
great thanks just wanted to wanted to
make sure
um
b takes c4 and currently black is down
upon but here's the whole problem this
pawn on b2 is essentially indefensible
in the long run
and the configuration that i've gotten
here is extremely beneficial because
i've got also the potential to go c3 at
some point and break through
if i take on b2 and i get two connected
passers the game is over
the game is the game is over immediately
uh so he cannot allow
the b2b to be captured scot-free
um
and that's why fabi goes brooks c1
counter-attacking a pawn on c4
okay who takes b2
rook takes c4
bishop takes a3
hitting upon on c5 and he goes c6
this stretch we played very very quickly
these moves are all essentially forced
b2 and knight c3
and this is the last
critical moment of the game now as luck
would have it it's move 39 i've got
about 10 minutes and i used almost all
of them to find the winning idea
um now it doesn't seem visually that
it's not clear how to evaluate this
position because the pawn on b2
could potentially be lost and then you
would have potentially mutually assured
destruction right you'd take on c6 and y
would take on b2
but i correctly diagnosed the
why not rook c1 before bishop b2
not sure where
[Music]
you know where where you're
asking that when rook c1 is i mean he
could go right d2 also but
uh this forces white into complete
passivity and the rook is tied down to
the pawn this is not a good defensive
scheme
so he rook c1 is correct i think it's
the best option
so
the whole problem
here is that the bishop on a3 is super
misplaced
it doesn't seem to be misplaced at first
because it seems to be quite well placed
it's defending the pawn the problem is
it's not doing anything else and it's
very easy to attack knight b1 rook a4
uh the bishop on a3 is
highly problematic
and as soon as i understood that i
spotted the correct maneuver you could
do this in many different ways bishop b7
bishop f6 i decided on bishop f8 just to
be safe transferring the bishop to g7
where it's going to be a defending the
pawn be unassailable in c
uh you know essentially creating
creating an unstoppable bind against
white's position
there's yeah this is the only winning
idea so fabi can do anything he wants he
goes knight b1
to g7 the knight is now tied down to the
pawn
uh and the key difference is that this
pawn as we have said already is
invincible
but white spawn on c6 is not invincible
because i can simply bring the king up
to d6
and then
win the pawn and if i win the pawn the
game is over immediately immediately
um
so
this was move 40
30 minutes have been added to the clock
fab you spent almost all of them on the
next couple of moves
um and it dawned on both of us at this
point that the game is essentially over
now white has one last attempt
to
you know
to stop
what seems to be the inevitable and that
is to use the king to block black's
king's path to d6
that's to get this king to d5 but
this is where i did the brunt of my
calculation and i showed this in the
post game press conference that king is
now vulnerable we can use that
vulnerability to get this rook around to
d1 rook d8 king c5
and rook d1 and all that needs to be
established here is that the c pawn does
not afford white sufficient counter play
c7
but the king slides in to stop the pawn
king b6 again threatening to promote but
the king goes back to see it and hear a
very important line
i was terrified when i first spotted
this white can go rook a4
and rook can come to a8
but somehow we have to find a way to
dislodge this king so that we can take
the pawn in comes the bishop
in comes the rook
the king maintains contact with the pawn
and here
there is um
relatively prosaic idea
you go bishop c5 check okay the king
cannot abandon the pawn it has to go
back to c6
now we grab the pawn on f2
and why did we grab that pawn not just
to win a pawn but rather to transfer the
bishop to g3 finally the king has to
relinquish its grip of the pawn which
means that we can now take the knight
because rook a8 is met with king takes
his sound
this is not the only win by the way but
it's it's the cleanest
it's the cleanest why not rookie six
after okay yeah rook d6 is also possible
but after king c5 there's a super nasty
detail if you take the pawn
you get checked on a7 and this leads to
very unclear consequences
of course black is not losing king b8
but
i mean rook f7 probably black is still
winning but it's super
you know it's unnecessary complications
so this was one very nice line
um another very nice line
was rookie for check in this position
white can try this
and then king b6
trying to get the king onto a vulnerable
spot and after rook b1 c7 you don't want
to go king see it and get checkmated
but here it might seem that white can go
rookie 7 and promote
if you calculate a little bit further
you notice that
all black needs to do is move the rook
away and then escape the checks all of
that's easy to do
um
and
black can do that in many different ways
rook c1 is probably the simplest check
king e6
check there should be five no more
checks and the pawn promotes
bond promotes
so
we were both calculating all this i was
calculating this when i played bishop f8
he was calculating this presumably here
and
you know this is all computer verified
it's lost if abby out of desperation he
goes h4 i mean
he's trying to basically trade king's
side pawns and try to liquidate but it's
not going to work i have
too many pawns on the king's side
and that's it it's over i win the pawn
and then i essentially go after the
knight rook b4 rook takes c6 goes rook
b7 a couple final moves get the bishop
out of the danger zone
and now i spotted the easiest win first
we go rook c2
hit the knight
knight can't stray too far from the b1
square otherwise i go king c6 and the
rook simply does not have any squares on
the b file
so king e3 to support the knight
and now king c6 the winning move
okay rook has only one key one square
which is b3 if he goes rook b4 he gets
forked
if he moves the rook away from the b
file we take on d2 and promote
but after rook b3 i can now slide my
rook to c3 trade rooks and simplify into
an even easier win bishop b4
um the knight is totally totally uh
stalemated and i have perfectly
positioned pawns which allows me the
right moment to create a passer with h5
and
white is overwhelmed trying to stop both
of them f4
king d5 avoiding h5
which leads to unnecessary complications
due to f5 notice how he he plays even
with one piece left he still finds a way
to set a trap which is quite an
incredible ability
uh but it's it's over um
d5 we stop f5 and only now do i go h5
f5 now we take and we drop the king back
to e6 to stop the pawn
king e4 g3 and bishop d6
hooking the bishop to the pawn the
winning plan is simply to take this one
and then just slowly but surely walk the
king all the way back to a2
and if white's king tries to help then
he pushed the g pawn at the right moment
so he resigned here
and that's the game i mean
you know it that's just how it happens
he made a couple of critical mistakes in
in key moments and
really it was only one mistake i think
he
i think the move that ultimately ended
up
turning the tide in my favor
was um
was knight c3 i honestly think this is
what did it did him in
not going for there's a risk-free
continuation up upon probably because he
judged that it was too drash
that's ultimately i think what turned
the tides
at that point he sort of never recovered
when did you get a sense that you were
going to win
i got that feeling when i played bishop
fa when i spotted this idea i started to
understand that
very high likelihood that white has
simply lost here with no hope
and at that point i was just i was
completely zeroed in
more focused than i've ever been because
you know you can't screw up such an
opportunity you just can't can't allow
that to happen
but i hope you guys enjoyed i mean this
is a very complex game a lot more to
talk about a lot more i could talk about
but i want to keep this pretty compact
so
i appreciate everybody
paying such careful attention
no reason bishop e7 was fine bishop d6
would allow f4 there's no reason to
play with fire here
um so you want to drop it back as far
you know as
you want to go as close as possible to
your camp
basically yeah thank you well i'll
definitely address the other games on
future streams for now i'm going to call
it a night guys
have a great
rest of your night and uh thanks again
for the support
[Music]
you